catherine et christian denis huisman et
moi même avons décidé de vous faire
faire un exercice dans le cadre de votre
examen cet exercice va consister à les
faire un reportage vous chez paco
rabanne et l'interviewer sur la mode de
l'an 2000 la robe de mariée de l'an 2000
quant à vous vous irez chez alexandre
qui va vous parler de la coiffure et du
maquillage en 2000 oui celle-là qui
n'est pas une robe de mariée et déjà
encore trop pudique nous demeurions 2005
doit beaucoup plus transparente parce
qu'il ya le lire à bouctouche sûr que
les progrès savoir le constate de la
nullité perçu des sous vêtements
il ya des collants 1 visite le corps qui
permettront justement des volets presque
intégralement et les robes sur des
espèces chose que vous l'avez là dessus
très transparence irisée brillant parce
qu'invisible totalement disparu c'est
très froid dans cette robe ivoire sera
dans les matières conservons une même
température
vous croyez que les tissus ont disparu
d'autres ont disparu parce que tu auras
une pénurie de matières premières ce
sera des matériaux synthétiques les
produits avec des particularités
chimiques extraordinaire l'intensité de
la lumière à charge aux pleurs
conserverons la même température et
changeront peut-être même surtout selon
l'humeur des gens en l'an 2000 les
femmes auront les cheveux rasés
on viendra les crânes et ce qui sera
amusant c'est de s'offrir des perruques
en bois comme celle ci et vous ça que
j'ai voulu faire la mariée de l'an 2000
avec des copeaux de bois argenté et des
antennes qui sont le symbole de l'amour
et du mariage de maquillage ou et et
pâle et les bouches sont noirs hollande
2500 par ip et l'oeil et agrandi par des
étoiles et les mouches sont des étoiles
aussi c'est le raffinement de la femme
qui est poussé très loin puisque les
crânes rasés en les pins la matière est
devenu le symbole de l'art et je crois
que la conclusion c'est de faire appel
et surtout de savoir s'en servir et de
l'attraper
[Musique]